now as summer comes to an end it's time
to soak up the best wine and cheese of
the season so here to help is diana
breyer of valley cheese and wine vegas's
oldest cheese and wine shop by the way
if you didn't know that that's right so
that means they know what they're doing
so welcome diana and i just have a
little tidbit i hear you're the wonder
woman of cheese and it's not because
she's beautiful and strong there's a lot
more to it right there is actually um
i'm an artisan cheese maker i'm an aphi
nour so somebody who can age the cheese
i'm a certified cheese sensory evaluator
one of 45 in the country and the only
one in las vegas and i'm a certified
cheese professional as well so coupled
with that and my name being diana and
these crazy tattoos wonder woman of
cheese was born wow i love that you need
like a reality show or something it's
called the wonder woman of cheese all
right so let's get to it this beautiful
spray we've got wine we've got
charcuterie so what do you have for us
so today i thought that it would be best
for us to just go ahead and bring some
summer and spring milk cheeses that are
going to really like help
usher us out of the summer season and
into some of these cooler weather months
hopefully soon right now i know as the
rain comes down through monsoon season
but actually i wanted to showcase some
of the brighter and more like really
easy drinking really easy eating cheeses
that are a great way to send off summer
with some great wines that pair
beautifully i'm excited all right so
teach us teach us okay let's start your
notebooks out look at your notebooks so
we're going to start with a white wine i
always like to start when we're tasting
wine to go white rose and then red so
we're going to start with our white wine
today you're drinking an oregon please
do today you're drinking an oregon
violet this is from a female winemaker
named lynn penner ash a vna is notably
floral has some nice like stone fruit
notes in there and we actually paired it
with a domestic cheese that is made with
100 goat's milk it's called tea rose
this one right here yes that one right
there it is a fresh unripened goat's
milk cheese now you can really really
taste that the girls are out to pasture
oh yeah you're going to get a crumbly
texture that smooths out into creaminess
gives you bright citrusy notes and
florals and then when you introduce that
wine back onto your palette with the
cheese still in there oh you mean i have
to drink again oh no yeah oh yeah you're
going to be drinking a couple sips at
least
okay and i have to say i do taste
rosemary on that cheese as well right
yes so that's covered in dried flowers
herbs and a little bit of fennel pollen
so you're gonna get really nice elevated
florals when you combine those two on
the palette and it's really just gonna
bring you the essence of summer just in
a in a beautiful pairing okay let's move
to the next one okay next one moving on
you're going to want to grab one of
those spreaders right in front of you
with the wooden handle
because this cheese is actually a soft
spreadable cheese called driftless and
it has an inclusion of lavender and
honey so this is 100 sheep's milk cheese
i'm gonna spread it oh shoot we have 15
seconds i'm going to spread it on my
grape
okay if you're going to get sweet you're
going to get florals you're going to add
a little bit of bubbly it's going to cut
right through and just saturate the
palette with beautiful friendly notes
this is delicious yeah it's a gorgeous
pairing for sure can i come hang out
with you every day tell everybody how
they can visit valley wine and cheese
valley cheese and wine is at 1570 west
horizon ridge parkway in henderson
it is a beautiful beautiful little shop
family owned and run so we are just
happy to have you anytime the wonder
woman of cheese thank you you're welcome
thanks for having me we'll be right back